[Music]
super cool to meet you bad you too yeah
thanks for coming out I've been
following you for a while all the
content that you put out so
inspirational and just high vibe man and
it's just awesome to finally meet you
do we have a similar group of friends we
do we have Venn diagram overlaps of
course John Joseph podcast favorite yes
is your boy big guys go way back right
yeah I met John a long time ago uh in
the early 90s Wow I used to see him we
still go to hip-hop clubs and he'd be
walking around by himself we like oh my
gosh John Joseph we like New Kids on the
scene uh-huh and so after after see him
a couple times he give us like the head
now with oh [ __ ] John he was a head nod
and that's how we kind of met him it
wasn't too hard it was to like the hip
hop show us really you have that's so
interesting but you knew him from
cro-mags and although of course of
course we scared that band yeah yeah but
like yeah we should see him walking on
the street but yeah just I have a really
good story about John tell it me and my
wife were crossing the second Avenue one
evening and my wife I was with my
friends my wife was with her friends and
they were ahead of us and there was a
old man coming he was kind of like
handicapped and my wife started helping
him across the street - and these - DJ
guys were coming by with all their gear
and they stopped and said something why
for like some derogatory stuff cause my
wife and I saw my wife like in this
guy's face like screaming a guy on the
street and I was kind of stuck in the
traffic and that this car pulls up super
fast and the guy jumps out I him say
that's my sister and he punches both the
dudes and takes to her DJ equipment and
jumps back in his car it drives away and
I was John Joseph oh my god I just got
goosebumps telling that story it was
like it was this surreal moment of like
oh my god John's like a superhero but he
just saw it jumped out quick just did it
protected her and then exited man like a
superhero move that's crazy
yeah that's classic though I mean one of
my favorite things to do when I go to
New York is just walk around his
neighborhood with him and if you pay
attention to the way that he treats
everybody that he encounters in one of
those experiences it's a it's a it's a
life lesson like he knows all the
shopkeeper
by their first name yes he knows their
family members you know he always asks
in on everybody he knows the names of
the you know kind of local people that
are living on the street and his
neighborhood he takes care of them he
looks after them he brings him food yeah
I mean the dude is a hundred and ten
percent of service and real through and
through yeah I love him he's a big
brother he's inspiration everything has
been through a survivor like you said he
was veganism and his iron man's and just
like his band and just the shape it is
in the way performs on stage at that age
I'm 49 he's 55 I think and huh I want to
be like that when I'm that age and he
just like you said he gives it one
hundred and twenty percent always yeah
and you guys share the same you know
ethos pretty much I mean both you know
influenced by the same bands both kind
of came up you know under the wing of
bad Marines and PMA and Napoleon Hill
and Minor Threat and you know that whole
kind of scene you know yeah you cut your
teeth in that world 100% especially in
the New York scene that's where for me I
found out about vegetarianism all that
stuff let's do the hardcore music I
think it's one of the most powerful
type-c music for me a person that's
affected me and it's when the first
jhana is a music that was singing about
animal rights uh vegetarianism in the
80s yeah so huh let's take it back man
so youyou you're originally from
Massachusetts right yeah born in Taunton
Massachusetts yes
yeah and trusty math two older brothers
yeah but we were saying for the podcast
I was listening to to Toby's guy's own
podcast and you did you in your first
episode was interviewing your mom yes
it's a heavy you know Massachusetts
accents hobby yeah but like talking
about back in the day like with your
brothers growing up and discovering
skateboarding and you know punk rock is
little kids and you know suffering the
loss of your dad at like oh you died
like really young right yeah I was 33 he
had a rare heart condition Wow and um
yeah so when that happened it was I was
kind of too young to realize I was only
3 you know much much about death but
soon after that my mom was working
several jobs to keep food on our table
as I move overhead and and so she had
three boys and so um she worked from job
to job
and then uh while my mom was working my
brothers would sneak me out to like punk
shows and stuff and they got me to
skateboarding and punk rock
mmm but the same time they actually they
were party in the house and drinking and
smoking so they kind of scared me to be
straight edge and sense uh-huh now they
turn me on to this crazy music that I
could skate aggressively to and then
through the punk rock like Sex Pistols
and Black Flag and bands like that I
found Minor Threat or had more of a
message I could relate to right so older
brothers always the ones who are you
know the influential figures yeah here's
the cool music here's what you should be
doing like we'll take care of you here's
a drug you should never do yeah so were
they out of control or what was it about
about their behavior that that made you
say like I don't want to I don't want to
go that route I think I just I mean one
time we came home and like the garage um
the cellar doors were open to the smoke
and they were downstairs with the
neighborhood girls like smoking weed and
stuff and I never seen that before I
never smoked weed I never seen it and
they were drinking stuff and just the
way they acted it's just kind of scared
because I looked up to them you know huh
and then I don't know well then once I
saw it affected them and then you know
heard the lyrics to straightish by minor
threat I was like oh my god
I'm 13 years old I never tried anything
and now I can skate to this band they're
super aggressive I love the lyrics and I
made a commitment from when I was 13
years old I'm never gonna try drinking
alcohol ever for us in my life and I did
it and I've been living like that my
whole life that's so crazy man I'm how I
did it never drank alcohol never smoked
weed never tried it Yeah right before we
start asked if you want any coffee
you're like I've only a coffee twice I'm
crazy yeah caffeine makes a little crazy
you are a pure vessel my friend yeah
it's crazy makes s it might suck my
tattoos that's whatever how I expressed
myself and hurt my skin but um yeah I
just never try anything
yeah and never never a moment where you
almost went there I mean how did so if
this music was like your buffer to
insulate yourself against the peer
pressure I would imagine right totally
it was that in skateboarding I mean I
definitely got made fun of at school for
like only like loving skateboarding I
didn't have a girlfriend
people call me names at school and you
found it pretty fast in school your
friends only not going to the cake
parties but I would go to K parties
actually I'll go to K parties and my
brothers and I'd be the young kid there
and they would give me all the money
they would say give Toby the money to go
get going to collect money for a beer
run and
all the money no girl I did it a couple
of times and I bought like you
skateboards and stuff was kind of lame
they just probably forget exactly but um
he found out pretty fast - your friends
are and um about like 10th 11th grade
people knew oh he was just a
breakdancing hyperactive skateboarding
kid who didn't drink and they love me
for who I was and that's that's my whole
point about everything I'm about is just
to be yourself because you know your
friends will love you for who you are
not
if you drink you're smoking out you know
yeah yeah yeah and that's like a big
part of a message that you take to young
people now yes for sure man the peer
pressure and to being yourself it sounds
so cliche but I speak at schools and
that's one of the main things I talked
about is the peer pressure and not
having to fit in and be a follower and
not mopping the fall but be a leader
right and follow your heart not people
so did you ever go through like a
preachy phase because you're very like
non-judgmental dude you're like to each
his own but was there did you get a
little holier-than-thou though as being
like the only kid who wasn't partaking I
don't know but I think I think that's
the biggest misconception about me that
I am preaching I call myself tici not
preachy and nobody my band straightedge
not on all of our songs about being
straightedge I'm surrounded by people my
wife's not straight as you've been
married for almost 25 years I'm not just
hanging out with vegans and straightedge
people my message was never like you
shouldn't do that you know because I
know it was like to have like a dare or
a scared-straight come to your school
and tell you not to do something and you
like for style down people's throats
it's like they're gonna do exactly that
you know what I mean like so my approach
is always just been leading by example
people ask me why I look young well I
have so much energy well I haven't ate
meat since 1988 or I never tried drugs
alcohol I'm trying to be an example of
that right not trying to be like because
I feel like sometimes vegans can be the
worst enemy you know and there's soap
reaching down your throat i'ma tell you
what to do and like forcing it down you
what kind of problem man
it is a big problem and you know I'm
empathy I'm a member of the community
and I'm empathetic to that sensibility
but at the same time it just works
across purposes with the bigger goal
which is getting people enthusiastic
about a lifestyle that means so much to
me but the minute you start telling
people they're doing it wrong
or are telling them they should be doing
this or should be doing that like you
just the keep bloodlines communication
to shut down completely and now it's
like when people try to go vegan but
they're not 100% like maybe they were in
leather shoes are wearing something
people like all of a sudden attacked
them and these are like big people are
trying to make a difference and it
really bums me out because nobody's
perfect it's impossible to be a perfect
vegan all the stuff they put in your
mouth at the dentist has been tested on
animals you're sitting on leather seats
on airplanes you're sitting on leather
seats and ubers it's impossible to be a
perfect human let alone be a perfect
vegan nobodies do our best yeah well
there's just like there's always
somebody who's more woke there's always
somebody who's more vegan and they're
they're pretty much ready to tell you
about it it's usually the one and it's
usually I once it's super-new they're
like six months vegan like all gung-ho
like yeah relax man
yeah it's like we're all human beings on
the spinning planet right yeah and I
feel like you want to scare people the
way because whether it's a trend or not
you're doing it for health or for vanity
do whatever you're doing it for we're
saving lives by you being vegan so I'm
happy that that's super popular now you
know I mean it's helping everything
uh-huh it's the most positive healthy
trend for everyone it's crazy how much
it's grown and exploded in recent years
like we were talking to before the
podcast like yeah King and Carl's jr.
and all these like fast food chains are
now offering you know vegan plant-based
burgers and you know more and more kind
of notable cultural figures or jumping
on board and it's like it's really
shifted culture in a huge way in recent
years I mean you've been doing this
forever man yeah it's amazing like not
to have to eat like falafel all the time
and not have those oh the hockey [ __ ]
the boat I still love Boca burgers just
the stuff we had to do this first first
not dogs that came out in the 90s and
it's just having all these options
especially them in California is like
not even real life here because it's
vegan everywhere but I just seen around
the whole world how things were changing
people be more conscious and it's funny
because all the bands that I was loving
youth of today and Gorilla Biscuits and
monitoring these bands were singing
about these messages in the 80s it's all
coming even cro-mags all coming full
circle now it's right it's crazy man
right right right well let's go back to
that time so you're skateboarding around
you've you discover punk rock you got
these older brothers who are messing
about and you start you guys start
moving around right like you end up in
Newport
yeah yeah moved to Newport Rhode Island
live they're doing the America's Cup
races got really heavily in the
skateboarding there I met a bunch of
great bands from that scene but that's
like you know a lot of pop collars and
you know it was yeah on Bellevue all
those mansions on Bellevue car easy
houses but we weren't living in the
crazy houses but you skateboard in their
front yards and stuff like that or what
you know what is this
I can't imagine skateboarding was like a
thing the other ones because there was
like the Scott subculture of like
skateboarders it was half fives there
was ramps on first Beach there was like
a store that had a halfpipe and there
was bands like verbo saw and vicious
circle and positive outlook and
proletariat all these like hardcore
bands were skaters Fred Smith was from
the area he was like a pro skater for
Alva and uhm yeah and I got started
getting heavily into skateboarding and
doing contests I was a freestyle
skateboard I got in Thrasher in 1983
it's like my biggest thing to happen for
second place in this skateboard contest
and there against at Rhode Island and
that was like you know just skating all
the time we skip school and go to thrift
stores and buy throw stop
store clothes and skate around and go to
the shows but yeah there was this
element of like a different level of
people there and then when the America's
Cup came it was old lady who had her
ankle broken by a skateboard so they
banned skateboarding in Newport Rhode
Island and we all went we marched to
City Hall we we protested I was like a
super young kid and we got we got the
law change back to we could skate again
uh-huh it was pretty cool you got picked
up by the cops right yeah yeah yeah I
went down the story gave my mom like a
pack of cigarettes video phones went to
the liquor store and a cop car came by
and said he put the lights on to ask me
come in the car and they put me in the
car was freaking out was like crying and
as he took around the corner there was
more skateboarders because they're
everywhere and I think I even said like
you can pick them up too when they
picked them up too and end up going to
the police station was like stacks of
skateboards and all my friends are in
there is like holy crap yeah did this
been skateboarding like that but you
guys got it overturned got it overturned
his first time ever like protest that's
like your first like punk rock like
thing that you did right yeah what the
city hallway sounds crazy but isn't
crazy that my mom didn't even come get
me for hours so be sure to go to work
there's no phones it seems like your mom
put you on a pretty long leash yeah pre
permissive yeah I think that she wasn't
like grinding you for being a skater kid
or anything
like it's really chewing she talks about
it now with me like no regrets but like
she let my brothers watch me I mean she
was trying to keep you know keep us
alive and [ __ ] so it's like I can swear
right yeah so um you know my brother's
not we're not we're not on rounding for
show but it's pretty cool you could do
what everyone at yeah so yeah I mean
yeah my mom let me hang my brothers yeah
and she trusted me I guess and she knew
I was she knew I didn't do any drugs she
knows a skateboarder she knows a punk
rocker and she still let me go and go to
the show see she never went to when the
punk shows to check it out for us we
went and seen so many great bands and
were they like all ages shows yeah
that's the other thing like there's so
many interesting things about like this
sector of music in that scene like it
was you know open it was there the
all-ages thing was unique about it great
the no drugs and alcohol straightedge
thing was unique about it like the vegan
aspect of it the positive mental
attitude like all of these things are
emblematic of the hardcore scene that I
think people miss or don't understand
because they see all these aggressive
heavily tattooed dudes screaming I think
it's violence and you know and they're
scared of it yeah it's crazy because yes
it's automatically judged by tattoos how
you look the sound of the music the
people stage-diving jumping on each
other the pig piles limbs if you see it
that's like a normal person they're like
what is going on here you know but when
you're in it and you're in the music and
the message and you're living it it's
something so magical in something so
special to your heart that stays with
you for the rest of your life and it's
something that no people always say punk
rock's huge and poet and this stuff it's
like it's it's sellouts and there's punk
rocks on the radio but the heart
Christine always stayed underground you
know it's still there and they're still
kids putting on shows and putting out
fanzines and new bands and like it's
this community and it's always been
looked at as it's scary violent thing
and it's it's totally opposite of that
you know the punk rock originally was
like anarchy in the UK and [ __ ] your
parents and destroy everything but
Harker was like let's fix things let's
fix everything that was that's it
difference to me of punk rock and
hardcore it's like hark was like let's
fix this make this make the world a
better place
it's not just sing about it that's like
that's March that's that's uh protests
there's pamphlets at the shows I saw the
first
ketta videos was that a hardcore show
that's where I first saw like the
slaughtering of animals I was like holy
[ __ ] you know and um so yeah this is
powerful message that people might never
ever get to experience to this day
because I always can look at Harker has
something like violent I mean while
people look at me on the train covered
in tattoos a wife-beater on and they
were like I try to give a seat to an old
lady she wouldn't sit next to me or
people pulling their children like I'm
thinking like I don't even eat meat I
haven't never tried a drug you guys are
looking at me like I'm a piece of [ __ ]
I never been arrested you know what I
mean like there's so many stereotypes
especially with tattoos well I mean you
know in fairness I mean look tattoos
were ubiquitous now but back then it was
like it was different just like it's
like what's going on it's confusing for
people it's scary guys they're not they
don't know what it is
sailors in criminals and like what is
that relationship between body art and
like the music and why do those things
go hand in hand with PMA like it's just
a recipe of things that that are just
new and different for people yeah yeah
and for us it was just like how we
expressed ourselves actually where our
hearts on our sleeves and we saw the
other bands like the cro-mags and Nasik
from these bands with tattoos and oh my
god I look so cool and then you want to
get stuff like one of my first tattoo is
it's like a meat is murder - in 1988 you
know it's not my first tattoos in my arm
and I never have I got a job at Subway
and they had ordered me a long sleeve
sure because even one me promoting that
kind of message at Subway and that was
in Maryland serving up like cold cuts
cheese story yeah yeah
how old were you when you got your first
tattoo I was 18 yeah and I'll catch you
be are you still getting them you have
any room left I just got this a couple
weeks ago ex
yeah yeah I'm starting to go here I
waited my whole life to go here but yeah
I've been getting tattoo since 80s max
for like straightedge
yes sir yeah so where does uh where does
the music start to come in for you as a
performer well I became a roadie in 1989
for a band called sick of it all for a
couple years I travel the world of them
I think oh to college that was my
college move right in New York mid so
you made in New York when you finish
high school all by myself at 18 my
yearbook says moved to New York City
support the scene and keep skating that
was a life plan what's mom doing good
luck exactly
my mom had already kicked me out of the
house I was living with my girlfriend in
her attic because my mom got a new
boyfriend the game of that can automate
him I get a job by this day and I got a
job at like Solomon's steakhouse or
something a dishwasher three days later
after they kicked me out anyway
I moved to New York I chopped up with
CBGB's it was really scary had you been
in New York before with my uncle like in
the early eighties like Empire State
Building assume it's the one place you
like CBGB that's at one place I noticed
take me there and drop me off yeah so
were you gonna stay that night yeah yes
sir so basically this man called token H
we played DC I became pen pals with them
literally the writing letters to Timmy
chunks the singer lived in Queens it was
over year span and he told me like you
wanna come out he can live with me for
him it was no big deal but for me I was
leaving everything my mom my brothers my
love of my life but I didn't care about
Maryland I want to get out so yeah I got
chopped up at a token entry show at
CBGB's and was totally scary had all my
[ __ ] with me and after that we drove out
to Queens and I ended up I moved in with
my friend Timmy chunks I lived here for
a couple months and they told me had to
move because the limo didn't know I was
living there yeah so I end up being like
sleeping on couches all through Queens
right right right and just showing up at
the shows and starting to you know make
friends with the community yeah maybe
friends of the community took me under
the wing there was like a lot of New
York ball-breaking they called me like
the girly man from Maryland there's a
lot of teasing I got a lot of thick skin
from moving to New York I didn't have it
kind of tough love growing up but all
these people my peers they really took
me under the wing and after I became a
roadie for a couple years I realized I
had things I wanted to say so I started
writing lyrics on Torah and that's where
my band started yeah that's kind of like
how John started right like being a
roadie for Bad Brains and having junior
kind of take him under totally yeah
traveling the world with the channel
yeah yeah so at some point you're like I
can do this
yeah I mean it's a good thing about
Harco is that you know me to be the best
singer no disrespect but as long as you
have a message and you have the passion
and you want to get it out that's the
best thing about that like the guys in
my band never even played instruments
really before we started playing guitar
with us so yeah I just started writing
lyrics
name I've been h2o he made stickers
started spreading the word through the
community there was no internet and I
would jump onstage had one song and I
play it on different people sets and I
played this one song and starting a
little buzz and then I yeah things
really took off
fast after that because start getting on
all these bigger bills and we get a
record deal me didn't we just happened
really fast
right like how fast like a year yeah I
mean like our first shows in Queens with
Murphy's Law and our second show is with
the cro-mags at the limelight a massive
venue and then after that our friends
sieve and say cabral took us to Europe
for six weeks we had five songs and one
t-shirt just happened so fast
Wow and I was singing and the way I look
the way I looked in the scene I was in
people weren't really singing and I I've
always been into melodic music so when
it came out I'm a more singer than
screamer so people that Colie crap
that's the roadie from the sick of all
and just the way I looked in her hung
out with I think didn't expect to sound
like h2o a to love song on a first 7
yeah yeah yeah I mean you're sopping
definitely more melodic yeah the typical
hardcore stuff and I got that from the
DC scene which I loved in the California
scene and yeah I mean Here I am 25 or 25
years later in the same band it's crazy
man Torin yeah yeah it's crazy like we
didn't have any hits on the radio didn't
sell a lot of records and it's just the
community and the longevity and people
love the message and now people are
bringing their children to our shows
people have grown up as bands my son
comes on tour with me now he plays a
song per night on drums with us yeah I
saw on Instagram he you took him out
like you went all over Europe yeah right
yeah he's been around the world he's
been everywhere experience yeah it's
awesome you ever do that for him too
yeah well he seems like a really I mean
not that Instagram is a window into
reality or anything like that but he
seems like a really unique cool
expressive kid yeah it's a very um
compassionate loving kid I'm really
lucky my boy at a really good job and
especially growing up in LA it's I was
from East my wife's from Chicago it's
kind of scary raising the kid in
California yeah especially with social
media and just all the different
pressures but he's it's cute cuz he did
this IG poll on his stories like just
people asking questions like are you gay
what's your favorite shoes they just
random questions and someone's like you
vape as like Nam straightedge and I read
it like last week I was like oh my god
like I wasn't supposed to see that he
was just doing that for like the people
that follow him like yeah I haven't ever
preached to him like you have to be like
this like he's never had me who never
eat meat he hates it he thinks it's
disgusting you won't even eat you won't
even eat the possible burgers are beyond
well he doesn't even eat that
Wow that's that's gonna take like a lot
of courage and strength and you know
composure and and self-confidence to
kind of navigate you know your peer
group and have that kind of conviction
yeah now this is a bunch of friends at
school were vegan because of him he's
really cool and they cater to him at
school with his with his diet at school
and I just it's more conscious world man
I think yeah people more younger kids
are - yeah it's cool but still we're how
do you have you sidestepped like that
kind of natural urge that I'm sure you
had when you were his age to kind of
repel and push back against you know the
parental unit I know it's crazy because
he listens to this crazy death metal
music that me my wife have never played
in the house it's the only type of music
me my wife do not like so we found this
genre music on his own that he loves and
it's totally insane music that it's like
I can't explain it but he found it on
his own so it's kind of his rebellion
against us in a way yeah and he has a
band and the band sounds like mr. bungle
and like some grunge 90 stuff has
nothing to do with my music so that's
cool right and what do you think you did
or are doing as a parent that has you
know kind of created this creature who
feels good about himself and you know
can kind of make his own way without
succumbing to all of these you know
pressures that lead us astray for us
it's communication it's another one
number one thing we talk about my house
is uh
we talk about everything with my son
from day one about any kind of bully and
just anything any pressure we have such
an open open relationship it's kind of
insane like sometimes like okay cool
that's nothing on here about that but we
talk about everything and this is a
total tight unit family man and my wife
grew up you know just her mom you know I
grew up just with my mom basically and
so Mack have like a full family
structure is so important to us and you
know I can't really I can't call my
dad's a member he took me fishing I
can't get any advice to my dad because I
don't have one so I do the best with all
the values I've learned from growing up
in punk rock - like instill them in my
son and it's just it's just a lot of
honesty and communication and love tons
of love and it's interesting because a
lot of his friends like to come over
hang at our house cuz we have like the
drums in the room like
like it's it's a good vibe you know and
um I don't know I think it's just being
honest with them and the non-judgmental
yeah no matter how cool you are and like
you're super cool like your kids don't
think you're cool right like you're just
dad and mom yeah I mean I feel like his
friends to come cooler than he thinks
I'm sure that's the case
yeah and I think that you know one day
when he's on his own looking back he
realize like wow I got to travel the
world and do this cool stuff I know he
sees it now like just based on the posts
that you put up and that he puts up like
I I get the sense that he understands
that ya know and I just think like when
he did that thing where was it with cat
fondue yeah you like did the makeup
thing with her I was like wow what
that's like amazing that he not only did
that but like shared it like he's
basically putting on makeup and dressing
up like a woman and like just Here I am
man yeah that took that took a lot of a
lot of heart to do he did a campaign for
cat for divine was a tribute to divine
and yeah it was a full drag queen and it
was she asked him dude was like sure he
didn't hesitate about doing it he was
nervous when you went through but once
it all the makeup on he started like
feeling himself he was like he was in it
like he really he loved it I mean there
was a lot of he got a lot of negative
stuff from some of those posts but he
wasn't caring about any of that stuff
but like people just like oh my god but
I was getting texts and random people
like that's so amazing your son so
probably do that and people hit me up
saying you know my kid is Tran Jen's
Mike just all people hit me up from all
different walks of life saying this is
so amazing and so powerful that your son
had the balls to do that and you did it
and yeah I was a really proud moment man
yeah yeah yeah well the anti-bullying
thing and you know it's so central to
like your message and even though like
on all your merch and your swag it's
like yeah and racism yeah all that kind
of stuff like that just seems like an
outgrowth of just this PMA sensibility
that goes way back to the day yeah 100%
I mean I feel like it's very contagious
to be a positive and to be and do the
best you can like I also posted I'm not
perfect I don't wake up every day like
everything's wonderful and I get to
press I get sad I go through his ID do
all that stuff I try to work out and
push through it but you know the main
thing is trying to push positivity
because I feel like it's really helped
me in my life I feel like you put
negative energy
out there it comes back to you it comes
back to you and who you surround
yourself with and positivity has always
been something that lived by with my
band with my marriage and being a father
it's really helped me and you seen the
good and everything it would be wild to
like wake up Napoleon Hill from the day
and go dude do you realize like how your
work as like permeated the subculture in
a certain way and still lives on yeah
it's you see that like it's somebody's
family members they have an Instagram
for him now oh they do yeah it's really
it's really popular and so they're doing
live feeds and stuff but somebody from
his family are running that yeah it's
just with that book in the 60s it's
thinking Grow Rich and success to a
positive mental attitude I always try to
push those books because those those are
the ones that inspired the Bad Brains
who then inspired me you know and Jonah
right right that's what yeah I just
thinking that mentality it's it's really
powerful man well growing up without a
dad did you you know seek out like
father figures in the scene like who
were who were the guys that kind of you
know washed out for you 100% the scene
kevin seconds from being called seven
seconds one of my favorite bands he was
a total father figure to me he knows it
I'm friends with him now Ian McKay from
Minor Threat 100% you know I live with
the gorillas biscuits guys and queens
that's where I got into vegetarianism so
like Willa biscuits and youth of today
there were big impacts on my life and
even like rusty pistachio the guitar
player in my band he was like a father
figure to me looking out for me but
definitely the music yeah looked up to
these bands Milo from descendents you
call these shows you see these guys on
stage and you love their music and the
lyrics and they inspire you and then -
after the dumb play and they're standing
right next to you at their merch booth
and you get to go say hi to them and
talk to them and that's so powerful in
the punk rock community that you know
everybody's all equal you know and to be
able to talk to your heroes like that I
was really impactful in my life yeah for
sure write them letters I got postcards
from Amica postcards from Ian MacKaye
from the 80s it's awesome it's crazy
yeah so where does the the vegetarian
veganism thing start to happen for you
so that kicks in in 1988 you know I was
a hip-hop kata and punk rock kid and
caris wanted this song called my
philosophy yeah we talked about
vegetarianism and I love krs-one if I
was one of the still one of the greatest
rappers ever and he started singing
about that and I was living with Gorilla
Biscuits and I
became vegetarian because of them and
then I sang on the record start today
and then a song called cats and dogs and
the course was thou shalt not kill so
that was really powerful being part of
that record right and we're all part of
this like straightedge vegetarian
hardcore scene and there was pamphlets
at all the shows and then there was
shelter became they brought Christian
into the scene so it was like around 88
he changed for me being New York at that
time was just it was so powerful yeah
John always says it--i'll it's vital did
you ever go to Angelica's kitchen oh
yeah yes he I think he worked there or
he worked somewhere he worked at some
like natural food market but that must
have been early you worked at prana
foods made yeah that's what checker
worked and mark super charts tons of
bands worked there and then there was um
yeah down to earth was Civ worked and
Purcell worked like all the hardcore
dues work at these vegetarian right
health food stores you could always go
get like a first scrounge of free mail
yes and then was Kate's joint yeah that
was man but I T John yeah angelica's was
great a good friend of my work that
plays for a long time Jellico's is great
r.i.p yeah it's no longer no but now
it's organic grill it's a great place
yeah yeah yeah Val I like handle though
79 I do yeah it's great
I mean it's that's like the that's like
the crossroads of New York telling us
like the fancy the fancy place yeah
that's what's all used to be - so right
and I know the man so you know tall from
that scene as well right yeah I know
tall from the New York scene yeah he's
come to our shows and uh funny story is
that I think in 1989 he hadn't he didn't
have enough money and he went to go buy
a t-shirt from sick of it all and I was
a roadie and he was a little use a
younger kid and he only had five bucks
so I sold him that t-shirt and when I
reconnected with him like nine or ten
years ago I he told me that story and
how he still had the same t-shirt never
got that day it's pretty amazing that's
crazy that's how he we connected yeah
and for people that are listening tell
Ronan is the chef and the proprietor of
crossroads yes like not only the best
vegan restaurant in LA it's like the
best restaurant yeah period
yes hundred percent Travis Barker who's
been on the show is part o and heart
about you just had your birthday party
there right yeah 50 no 49 all right man
you got another year 49 but that was
like a who's who of like
musician vegan people awesome Moby yeah
there Oh Travis yeah it was a good vibe
I love crossroads but I'm so proud at
all and everything he's done and so
crazy yeah just the world peace starts
in the kitchen it's so smart and so true
yeah so how do you think about that like
spiritually what the veganism yeah I
mean I feel like living a cruelty-free
life and not harming animals and not
harming the planet and doing the best
you can every day is such a spiritual
life and it's such a positive thing to
be involved in that I feel like it makes
you a better person it makes me feel
happy with what I'm doing for the planet
for I don't know I just feel like
everything about it is a it's been a
spiritual journey especially seeing how
the world is changing and see how it
affects other people and I don't know I
just and I feel like if everybody was
living this way
it'd just be in such a different world
man it's just I know I know we're
getting there I know some day could
happen when I'm gone and my son still
walking this planet that you know
slaughterhouses are gone and all that
stuff but I feel like the spiritual
journey for me it's been knowing every
day that I'm not hurting anything or
hurting anyone and doing my best to be a
perfect human which I'm not but I don't
know it's for me it's I don't know it's
just something positive it's something
that I feel like it's no brainer I feel
like there's so many options it's 2019 I
can't stand when people say where do you
get your protein from makes me so angry
it's just it's just it has a non
judgmental dude you should be able to
like manage that one I know it's coming
it's an opportunity if like looks
sometimes somebody's throwing that at
you but sometimes they really don't know
it's true you know yeah I'd like to post
stuff about that a lot but proteins up
and pictures of gorillas and stuff but
yeah I mean it's it's an amazing time to
be a vegan it's amazing time to see the
planet change and I never expect it to
be like this with the fast food spots
and just people that I grew up with and
people that no one I've been like this
all of a sudden they are not because of
me maybe it's because of health reasons
or they watched what the health or
something but they change I'm like oh my
god really you did you know that was me
the whole time next to you but I never
said I didn't like yeah be like me it's
just cool to see people more conscious
you know this is all about youth of
today called no more and it was an anti
meet song in the 80s and they're like
they're like smashing hamburgers and
stuff and one of the lyrics is um we'll
have a more conscious caring Society and
that's exactly what we're having right
now yes crazy man it's pretty cool yeah
what was the kind of freestyle that you
threw down in your podcast were you like
no meat straight no drugs just make that
up yes I know I just made it up on the
web and I did a freestyle yeah my first
podcast yeah I'm never gonna love
hip-hop so much burn huh I would never
have because I just write the culture
too much but fed you to be a good name
though yeah do you uh I mean you're like
a grounded you see you seem like you
have a good like healthy grasp on on
like humility and gratitude like is that
a is that a practice does that come
natural is that an outgrowth I've just
kind of like this lifestyle that you've
been living for so long or how do you
think about that I don't really think
about it I mean I definitely I
definitely feel that I'm very lucky to
do it I love for this many years and I
built this life for myself through
pretty much nothing and I'm very um I
appreciate it and love it I worked hard
to get to where I am with my band and
but the fact that I have no boss and I
get to do what I want and still play
music at 49 years old I'm very lucky I
hate to say they hate the feel the word
blessed around because that's still not
around up I definitely pay my dues and
I'm blessed to be still doing what I do
and I feel like the key to being
positive and being happy
it can't happen for everyone but if you
do doing what you love is the key to
that man I feel like doing what you love
keeps you positive and happy it keeps
you young
I know there's people that are positive
that work crappy jobs from 9:00 to 5:00
and they hate it and they work in a
cubicle and they and they're in there
and they're positive too but I feel like
to really have control of your life and
be your own boss and do it your love I
really I feel like there's no reason why
you shouldn't be happy and be positive
because you get to do what you love and
I feel like I'm very lucky to still do
that I do only have a plan B and I
really had a plan B I just live my life
and that's kind of stressed my wife out
for a whole marriage um is that I just I
just live and I just I never had a plan
I just did it I did the band and it's 25
years later I have a non-profit I speak
at schools have a podcast
the things I do my merch does really
well I'm thankful for that but I just
get to live this life and I think it
kind of kind of bucks people out a lot
because I'm like like you're just a
hardcore doing it man how you doing this
I just I hustle man I really early focus
on trying to do good and put good out
there and I don't know I mean I just I
live a good life I'm lucky I'm healthy
let's get all my blood shed you got my
heart check cuz I was always worried
about my dad and got all that done and
every time I get that done my doctor's
like you're healthy I was 18 year old
girl I'm like nice man yeah well no Plan
B I mean I would imagine when you said
I'm going to New York there were a bunch
of people rolling their eyes oh my this
is gonna last but yeah so like show up
and like create something out of nothing
and you know if if you could like go
back and and and talk to that eighteen
year old kid as a 49 year old who's
still like doing the thing that you were
trying to do at that age it's like
insane I mean what an incredible gift
yeah it's and it's like I wasn't I'm not
a singer like I just it just it just
started singing I didn't plan that I
went to New York how do you saw music
worked at record labels was a road even
started the band and then yeah I met my
wife on tour like so many good things
happen when I got involved in this scene
in New York because I'd already been in
Rhode Island and DC but New York was
something way special yeah and yeah I
just I feel like it is the positivity
it's not giving up it's focusing on what
you love it's sticking to it it's
staying relevant it's keeping the
passion I still love what I do my band
and my brothers I hang out with them on
a daily basis I talk to me every day we
love each other it's not going onstage
going through the motions for money we
love each other we love these songs we
still live these lyrics that we wrote
over 25 years ago it's the same guys in
the band from everyone except my brother
yeah Wow it goes back and forth he's
right spring now yeah yeah yeah
so yeah it's the same guys I mean most
bands you know don't make it past you
know the first year or two right and to
be still doing it together and to say
you love those guys like that's like
what is that what is that like recipe I
died I think it's just we never took
ourselves too seriously
well not the tightest band we are pretty
sloppy at times but it's about the
message and how we get it out we love
each other with it with his friends and
we love what we do and we've had
different
million managers and booking Asians
we're on a major label independent label
we weren't Conan O'Brien weight on MTV
but all that stuff didn't affect who we
were as people like it didn't matter
what label we were still the same dudes
and we always stayed humble and really
appreciated where we were
we played Conan O'Brien had John Joseph
in the audience he was like the only
friend we have in the audience he was a
young between takes and on all the amps
know yeah he's so proud and we wore like
all of our friends favorite band tees we
took tape and did shoutouts and tags all
of our amps because we knew that this
may never happen again and it didn't but
you know the first New York Harker band
to be on late-night television we were
so excited man we appreciated it and
that just those moments like that we've
never took for granted and um I think
people can relate to our lyrics and they
know it's coming from somewhere real and
real experiences I've always wore my
heart on my sleeve I had my wife on the
cover my for a 7-inch I've always put my
family out there I probably shared my
life with people I have nothing to hide
I'm just this is who I am and I don't
know I just feel like that resonates
with people and and we're lucky that
people can connect to it yeah well I
think it's anchored in the DIY roots of
the hardcore you know subculture because
you weren't you didn't set out to become
a pop star or like a huge rock and roll
band that world is all about stickers
and flyers and your friends and and it's
like you're not you're not in it to like
get huge right so anything that comes
out of it is like gravy so it's almost
like the healthy gratitude for anything
that happens is that is packed into it
how percent like yeah it was there was
no goals of like we need to be on
television in the radio it was no that's
not we just want to play music was there
the words that were that it was there
some backlash though after Conan like
like the sellout oh yeah for sure
because we just signed to a major label
and that was like the Internet and the
message board started popping and people
would talk about a crap one there but I
think you know a lot of [ __ ] for that
record but once again we took a chance
and we did a record that was with a
bigger producing we had a more polished
sound because we were listening to not
just Harker with us than other types of
music and we had opportunity and we went
to him saying we tried it and it didn't
work out we tried it and then but but
the cone arriving
help at the same time that all now
they're on television right and it's
like you wouldn't you want like your
favorite band to like get their message
out further if you believe in their
message wouldn't want other people to
hear the message too and get it out to a
bigger audience and that was the whole
thing for us like we wouldn't just tour
with hardcore bands we tour a poppy
bands with we take chances and have an
audience who never hurt us before I love
the challenge to win them over and we
just want to get the message out and
that was the whole point from day one
using this van as a vessel to spread our
message uh-huh so um we tried with the
major label it wasn't horrible thing but
we got we got caught up in the mix of
the other bands and the timing and stuff
but it was a fun experience you know
yeah
well as somebody who lives their life
pretty transparently online and as as
somebody who's all about positivity how
do you navigate like the treacherous
waters of like toxic social media it's
it's hard can be really draining
sometimes I tell my friends I'm - I'm
too emo for Instagram I'm too either
because sometimes I do that it get to me
emo dub emo dad and sometimes I do even
like it could be like a hundred amazing
comments and then one negative one out
just like I don't know just get bummed
that sometimes I'd am like hey I try to
have a conversation because I want to
know what the problem is I want to talk
to him about it I don't just want to
delete them or block them I actually try
to see what should what your beef is
with me first
because I do take it maybe a I take it
personally because it's my everything
it's my heart and what I put out there
is really me it's like I'm not I'm not
candy coating anything our post is
really me and sometimes people take it
as really that's you like some people
get bone I like Coldplay they get so
offended by that because I'm supposed to
be a hardcore dude I can't like other
types of music but yeah it's hard man
it's a really positive tool to promote
yourself and promote a message and
promote your merchandise and you know
spread everything you're doing and the
other hand it's like a real negative
dark place man
yeah when sometimes you get caught up in
that just skin cut off going down these
rabid spirals yeah even like political
stuff just everything it's like it's
draining man yeah I guess you could
check on your phone how many hours you
spend on that I haven't done that yet I
shouldn't know but like at the same time
it's like I talk but when when Instagram
went down a couple weeks ago for like
that 15 hours or whatever I had a drop I
was dropping on Friday and I just
realized in that day like holy crap this
is how I'm a
my living it's really scary that's how
you promote all my stuff I'm on Twitter
to buy like and Facebook buy like I'm
like wow this is such a powerful tool
and like hope it's up so I can promote
my new thing dropping Fri it's kind of
scary man yeah that if it if it got
taken away then you're cut off at the
yeah that's kind of scary man yeah you
probably do you have like an email list
and stuff like that like that's yeah you
should think like anybody from hardcore
would hang out some crazy email list of
people that goes back to you know the
90s maybe Facebook what you do it yeah
that was a scary moment I was like holy
crap this is kind of obviously make
money from touring that's all yeah but I
like that you're like a lover you're
like yeah I love Coldplay like I bet
that you put that that poster that thing
about the Backstreet Boys
no Backstreet Boys and it's funny
because like the toughest nearly fall
off guard
I know and the toughest dudes but you
were like there to like I see some of
the comments it's like it's okay to like
other types II mean you could be
hardcore you'd be tatted up but it's
okay to like other music man you
shouldn't live your life with blinders
on it's like how about just celebrating
any artist that's putting themselves out
there try to do something all right
percent you know 100 percent man like
two people do all the band tattoos ahead
of my body of like u2 and Madonna and
all this stuff what I'm just people do
know I have like a hundred band tattoos
and it's not just hardcore like I like
everything I'd keep my mind open where
did the to walk me through how you got
involved in in doing the public speaking
thing with kids oh yeah so how about a
nonprofit called one life one chance
that's named after one of our songs more
record F ttw 1999 basically there was a
girl at a school in Far Rockaway Queens
who was a fan of h2o
and she made a team a mix CD for her
students for a spring break it was like
all a bunch of bands and just one song
by h2o is called Sunday it's a heavy
song about my dad
and becoming a dad and so when they came
back the number one song on this p.m. a
mix CD they connected to was the song
called Sunday and so she's like I'm
gonna send you some letter so she sent
me letters from every kid in the class
breaking down to me why they loved that
song I could get through maybe the third
one I was bawling just reading these
letters these kids knew nothing about
hardcore punk rock nothing
she's like next time we come to New York
come by me
you should talk to them I'm like about
why she's like your straightedge you're
vegan you're a dad you're fully tattooed
stereotype so it's like okay so I
started writing all these notes and cue
cards I put a PowerPoint presentation to
get which I've never done in my life I
was so freaking good talk I was so
nervous man I went to the school to a
metal detectives it was super gnarly
getting to the classroom how my power my
PowerPoint have all my cards I just had
my mic and then like I just start
talking I start doing my thing I didn't
look at my cards one time ever again
never had to started telling my story
and then like after that I did a Q&A and
everybody stood up and asked me
questions they read me their letters it
was hugging it was crying it was such
it's a connection I had never
experienced in my life it's not like
playing a show where kids know who you
are they come see you they pay the money
they sing along these kids who know who
I was I'm some tattooed freak in the
front of the class telling my story and
it talked about I talk about my friends
who passed from drugs and alcohol
growing up no dad racism positivity
punk-rock skateboarding everything and
it's just really connected and I
remember walking out of that school my
friend Vaughn Lewis who took me that's
Hall was there too and I said I want to
do that I want to keep doing this and
then immediately once I posted about it
every single punk rock hardcore kid who
was like on the PTA or like a teacher or
counselor or principal all hitting me up
so just on the strength of me and my
bands I started going to all these
schools Wow
and so it all drove you to that first
yeah they did he was like talking I was
so nervous so what were you what what
was the message like what were you
imparting that that connected so deeply
with these kids I think for those kids
that I'm up there with a t-shirt on
covered in tattoos as soon as I walk in
there's no way in the world even know
what straight edges wouldn't ever
imagine that somebody who does what I do
and looks like I look will never try
drugs in the house call that totally
bugged out the kids first and foremost I
wasn't saying I'm a recovering addict I
lost my wife and my kids for drugs I
never experienced any of it most of the
kids I spoke to probably more experience
with drugs and I did and then I just
told this story these are my friends
these are some people you might
recognize who were celebrities who live
as straight as you being in lifestyle
whatever I had a bunch of friends in
there and they were connecting with that
and I think it was just a connection to
me just being real and honest and then
the Q&A is my favorite part because
that's when people actually actually
really in serious questions some
pull me to the side after the after the
thing and they start crying tell me
about like how the mom and dad fight in
the house and smoke weed or my daughter
lost her life to driving this crazy
intense stories like and by the time I'm
out of there kids are like handing me
from the time I do the second
presentation they're like writing one
like one chance and strategy draw me all
these pictures their DM and me it's an
immediate connection that's it's so
overwhelming and um I don't know my main
fear going there was like I can't swear
I'm such a sailor on stage I can't say
[ __ ] I can't swear I was so scared about
swearing the whole entire time I've
never sworn in any schools I've done
like 36 schools and I swore once but um
yeah it was really I think John came to
want to think in New York we gave away a
drum set to a school needed Travis I
didn't video with Travis we surprised
the school and gave a drum set I started
asking schools what they needed for
their music departments it got really
good it's just really hard to do that
because there's a lot of red tape
involved it's not like booking a show
they want you when they want you and so
I was trying to do h2o shows and then do
a school but I'd be like so tired by the
time I get to the school it's hard man
because the schools you really want you
to have no money to get you there yeah
so that became really frustrating for me
and I haven't done one in a minute
because I got really busy with my band
and I just loved it so I just spiraled
from that then I just took like a year
to get my nonprofit status that's
amazing I have a board of directors
right now and how are you raising money
and what are you doing with the money
that you raised for that I haven't
raised really any money I think it's
Travis Barker step this it's really hard
Travis Barker stepped in the first time
and he helped me out we had merchandise
and all this cool stuff he raises Thank
You Travis for that for a couple of
schools he got me and then just I just
been doing it myself I do it for free I
just go out and play a show and a book
around it I'm like I wasn't trying I'm
not trying to make money off it I love
talking to the kid and spraying the
message but in reality it's really hard
to get me across the country to do that
you know and so just basically using the
nonprofit to underwrite the expenses
required so that you can show up at
these schools totally yeah I mean I
would do is talk I've met with so many
different people in the course of 10
years about what they could do I wanted
to do an arrow fell through or just
different ideas and like this traveling
school tour which we've tried to do
which have been awesome like I wanted I
still want to do it I love doing it I
still get hit up about doing it all the
time it's just frustrating because it's
just hard to do it especially with my
tour schedule and everything else going
I'm trying to balance it all but I love
doing it and all the people that got me
to the school is the first ones I
appreciate them for believing in me to
come there because I didn't have any I
didn't go to college to be a speaker or
anything it's like I didn't have any
background for that something like
college ready I'm just me I'm just a
singer in a punk band yeah but that's
what's powerful that's yeah connects
with feet that's rent truth and
authenticity and that lack of judgement
and and just having your guard down and
speaking to them like human beings yeah
I think that's what it was it was very
it was very real and just honest and I
just I just told everything about my
life but just yeah I mean so I think
that's really were connected with it
originally and um yeah it was really fun
doing that one keep doing it just it's
just hard it sucks cuz I waited so long
to get my nonprofit now I have a
non-profit and really not do anything
with it now so yeah I'll definitely get
back to it once I'm done nah
right on my touring life well I've got a
teenage daughter and a preteen daughter
I got two older boys that are musicians
that just moved out they live in Echo
Park now awesome pursuing the music
thing it's awesome I'll tell you more
about that later yeah but with the
daughters especially the teenage
daughter like I'm I'm really in touch
with just how intense like the peer
pressure is and this sort of pressures
that come with adhering to kind of a
certain social structure and how
important it is like where you fall in
that kind of like pecking order of your
friends and it's so intense and it's
just exacerbated by you know the phones
that we have in our pockets that
basically allow you know young people to
kind of see where everybody is at all
moments and who's doing well and who's
not and the FOMO and like who the cool
kids are like it's just yeah I can't
imagine having to contend with that when
I was at that age yeah we didn't have
phones we like played outside we skated
we did creative things went to shows we
did all kinds of cool things we got to
do that and so it's like my son would
never know a world without phones or
social media and it's crazy to see him
on his phone and I don't know what he's
I try to like be in the mix on what he's
I totally trust him I know as I do
anything crazy but it's just the
pressures and the different things and
it's like this Kardashian world of like
expectations for women to look a certain
way and be a certain way and yeah
looking at people and seeing what
they're doing either with
doing that not doing that like the whole
whole fire festival thing that is a
perfect example of it but just like the
realness of it and like you said like
being accepted and being down and
everybody's at Coachella just to get
their picture taken at Coachella don't
care about the music and I feel like I'm
posted the other day I saw like if they
just had those like fancy backdrops a
coach no there were no bands like all
the same people would still show up it's
a chance to cram pictures it's true me
it's like that and like also just with
the bullying to like we would go to
school and people would talk crap to us
and let me go home with our parents
would be safe it just continues now on
the phones all night long whether at
home on the phone social media the kids
can escape any kind of pressure and
negativity now yeah it's with them 24/7
and um
it's scary it's definitely scary to me a
parent definitely scared that but that's
what I'm saying the communication super
important as long as you communicate
with your kids you know exactly what
they're going through and dealing with
hopefully they tell you everything but
as I see my son taking selfies all day
I'm like what are you doing is it go I'm
doing my I'm doing I forgot his calm in
my stream on the streets this Teresa my
streets is a and like my phrases like
but that's that the program is designed
to keep you on it by like creating this
pressure around these streaks
it's insane you're just playing into
their own game like their game that they
set the rules to I think Steve Jobs said
like you wanted to create like the human
extension extension of the human body I
think that's what he was saying about
the phone actually yeah but you wouldn't
let his kids use the phone or the iPad
really yeah I even know that yeah wow
man yeah it's it's intense I feel like
there's so much before like for young
girls to be the magazine's they got and
like see the skinny models on the front
you have to go like to the kind of
subscription will go buy the magazines
in the mall now it's just like scrolling
or only look like that I need to look
like that get my lips like that I can't
imagine I came in imagine man the
pressures especially what we live yeah
we're like in the heart of it man I know
it's the belly of the beast it is and
Russians are right down the road here
like literally down the street from us
and then they had the lip challenge that
one time the people were cut in their
face that was sucking on glass to make
the lips pop that was a crazy thing so I
don't know about that oh yeah I was like
the lip challenge where they put their
lips in a glass and he suck it out and
then lips would pop
and then to get fat lips for a minute oh
my god is this create it's like and the
people like not really working hard to
be famous I want to be famous on social
media and make money off that but really
have no you can be pretty and stuff it's
just like the work ethic it's all that's
so different out in YouTube just be
famous do a couple goofy videos you'd be
like multi-millionaire my sons tell me
about all these youtubers and something
like what with these big houses and all
these cars I'm just doing YouTube silly
videos it's crazy easy world out there
well one of the things that you talk
about all the time is like role models
like how can you be a role model like
some people don't want to be a role
model a lot of musicians are like I'm
alright you know I'm a musician I'm not
a role model but you've kind of like
step willingly like kind of embraced
this role and one of the things you talk
about all the time is like look we don't
have we need healthier role models out
there for for young people especially
you know given what you just said 100%
and like first and foremost not just a
role model as a musician but as a parent
I think it's our number-one job to be
role models for our parents for our
children because if we're not their role
models are gonna find it in somebody
else's may not be so positive
inspirational and compassionate can we
look outside their household for some I
don't know some other artist or just to
where it may be some way other school or
so it's really important to be a role
model for our children so they can look
up to look up to us and they don't have
to look up to us but we want to lead by
example just like I say my music and
everything I post I want to lead by
example be living proof that you can
live a certain way and still have a fun
successful happy life but yeah I mean as
far as role model is concerned I don't
consider myself one maybe I can I try to
be the best in my as a husband and as a
father and if I am one in music that's
great I feel like not to toot my own
horn but yeah if I if I was if I was to
be a role model for somebody maybe I'm a
good example because I don't I don't do
drugs at home party I don't eat animals
I exercise I try to be positive I tried
a good good message out there
I'm not telling people look up to me I'm
not telling people that I should be
their role model but you know when you
have this platform and you're sing in a
band and you inspire people you do have
some sort of rollover
accountability not accountability maybe
if you're writing these lyrics that
people love me and you should be living
by those lyrics some people just don't
live there lyrics or live what they're
talking about his singing about and I
live those lyrics and so people look up
to me for a certain song that I wrote
yeah I wrote that song and I meant it
and I live it and so yeah I mean I'm
just me and I'm not trying to be like
look at me you should look up to me I
should be your role model but as far as
my son is concerned like he tells me all
the time that I'm his role model and I'm
like is here or whatever and that's just
me being me I'm not trying to portray a
certain image or portray a certain thing
to make myself look better cuz I'm not a
perfect person like I keep saying but
yeah the for role models for my son he
like I mean it doesn't get better than
that for your selection hip-hop it's
like that's what they're supposed to do
they're supposed to listen did you know
this as well as anyone the next
generation is supposed to fall in music
in love with music that you don't
understand true but like everything I
represent is the total opposite because
you have an expectation that you even
like on the most open-minded person in
the world when it comes to music so of
course he goes and he finds the one kind
of music I've gotta like celebrate that
because that's it's true your DNA yeah
you know and you know it's true and I
say this at the schools to like I met I
met Snoop Dogg I love Snoop Dogg but I
don't smoke we like Snoop Dogg that's
why I say at the schools you can love an
artist looked up to him loved the music
we have to try to be exactly like them
so it's like yeah my selling listens to
like little pump but my son doesn't do
any drugs so that's my dog loves like
some pretty hardcore hip-hop or water
just I mean dude you know I don't even
know like that's how old and out of it I
am like it's all about like you know
smoking weed and like you know the [ __ ]
is and like and she's like a very strong
convicted person like I don't worry
about her she's a you know she knows
what she wants out of life and like she
yeah she doesn't take any [ __ ] from
anyone and like she's you know got her
stuff together in a big way but am i
confused yeah like why why are you into
this like massagin
stick you know kind of music and I you
don't understand like it's it's the same
thing right yeah I mean I I love snoop
dogg never smoked weed I love gangsta
rap and everything arrested I never I
never you know and I mean so that kind
of I like a lot of hard stuff too it
doesn't mean that I think I'm hard or I
think I should be like them I appreciate
their story the message where they come
from the music to beat the lyrics
that's so much I mean I love hip-hop but
obviously I don't I think we're up in
the way certain rappers do but I respect
him like it so she might be like I get
this vibe it's coming from a different
perspective and a different community
and life I don't know I'm it's it's
weird how the kids are connected some
really crazy hip-hop man like really
like violin
it's weird also how in the me to era
like all of that stuff somehow it gets a
pass yeah like why aren't we like up in
arms about some of that stuff it's true
but it's been going on so long to like
would to live just like oh that's the
house snoop gets to smoke dope wherever
he goes like it's just their
grandfathered in or something yeah yeah
yeah it's true you have this she was
just part of it's part of its persona
it's part of who he is I mean it's
interesting it's weird right yeah
everywhere yeah regular green juice one
of the things that I that I do worry
about with the phones and the technology
and all of that and I'm interested in
your perspective as a creative person is
is it seems like you have to really have
discipline and erect boundaries around
these things in order to find like the
internal time to kind of tap into that
creativity like you've got in order to
be an expressive person you have to
allow yourself to be bored right yeah we
no longer hired never have to be bored
again we're always entertained and I
feel like that and I see this in my own
self like that can be a barricade or a
block to actually tapping into the
things that you know are percolating
under the surface that I want to express
but if I'm just scrolling all the time
yeah standing in lines or whatever like
I never get to connect with that and
when you have a younger generation
that's coming up that doesn't know
what it's like to have those kinds of
experiences what is that going to look
like 10 years from now 20 years from now
in terms of the kind of art that's going
to get created I know it's scary because
I saw that gun when Kanye West was doing
his record he he like totally turned off
and went to Montana or something like to
get away from all that and I think
that's what people have to turn off
their phones yeah and go to some
secluded area and try get inspired but
it's kind of for me I know if I could go
to some like woods and try to get
inspired to write a song I don't know I
like the energy the people around me I
like living and being involved in things
and being inspired like that
well life life enriches art but that's
different from being addicted to your
screen I know I feel like kids now they
think they click through and they say oh
I'm gonna be like that or sound like
that'll look like that and that's how
they get inspired they kind of I want to
kind of copy it I don't know the
originality is kind of but there's a
difference between consuming that
content and it's fine to be inspired by
certain people versus you know using
those devices to create because they're
also super powerful for that like you
see kids that are 12 years old that look
you know that could like edit a feature
movie you know yeah that's true that's
crazy man and think like all the
photographers now we may be losing jobs
and money because the phones are just
right used to take photos with that like
all the photography is on phones and
just the different things you could do
with the phone they'd only have to have
an education for a skill for and just I
don't know it's yeah man
I haven't read a record in a while but
when I do I definitely don't get
inspired on my phone for sure I start
just writing stuff and going my backyard
my picnic table and to start writing
ideas and things that I want to sing
about it would inspire about how does
that process look for you I just I just
write down basically when I write songs
I take a notebook like that and I just
write down this things I'm feeling are
thoughts or even like an idea like I'm
gonna song about skating or this and
that I just write it and just start
writing stuff and then I put it all
together and make it sound right you
know I mean I just I just write and then
I try to put everything together make it
make sense but yeah I just think about
things I'm going through a life is for
me it's like I don't know if I'm gonna
make another record I we did I record
like I don't know four years ago and it
was like I feel like that was like one
of our last records and we never forced
the records like we've been together 25
years and maybe we have six
albums that's really mad for a man's
career it's not a lot of records so I
feel like we make records when we're
inspired we don't like somebody on just
put records out every year so they can
go tour but we don't do that we just
wait to inspire but yeah I've been
really inspired to really write about
things I feel like you still tour like
every year yeah touring is different for
sure we have like a catalog of songs
that we're celebrating 25 years this
year we're celebrating 20 years at one
of other records so every year we have
an anniversary which is awesome when you
become older band you can go and go on
these tours and so do those like summer
festivals and yeah that like what are
some of the good places where you have
huge fan base um
Europe's amazing South America is
incredible that's our biggest places is
Europe and South America is great it's
just been oversaturated with bands for
many many years we have great places and
we play in the US but it's not like it
is in Europe in South America and
Southeast Asia would you have thought
that like hardcore would still be
kicking it like this this I never even
thought about that and I have friends
who have been in bands for like over 30
years and they still kill it they tore a
full time they're older than me they're
still great live and they still make
records and people still care it's an
amazing John room usik man this
something about hardcore punk it it just
goes for generations and generations and
nobody has to be selling millions of
albums or on television there's just
this underground family and you're very
lucky you can make your living you can
make your way totally crazy yeah very
lucky the festivals in Europe are
amazing and thinking about Europe is
like they stack a festival so it could
be like h2o wu-tang clan agnostic front
cro-mags it could be all these bands
together on one festival that would
never happen in America yeah like it's
crazy I can Czech Republic or Belgium
there's like I end up playing with my
friends mostly overseas and they do in
America because you crossed paths with
them all summer long
it's really awesome I checked the
schedule I'm gonna play with those guys
those guys it's really cool you've
toured were some big bands though over
the years yeah we definitely uh we did
some great tours with some diverse
popular bands yeah like I remember um
it's a band
thirty Seconds to Mars was opening up
for us on one of the tour suite a before
they blew up with the used and did Box
Car Racer New Found Glory blink-182
rancid The Mighty
ah stones they took us on the first
couple tours on that on that note of
like you don't have to be the biggest
band in the world if you have like just
a devoted fan base and you can like make
a living and do your thing the thirty
Seconds to Mars guys really like figured
that out like yeah just go direct to
their audience and not worry about you
know billboard and like the record
companies and all that kind of stuff and
one of the things that they do maybe you
know about this or been to if they do
this annual thing called camp Mars yeah
it's right down the street here like a
run out like this camp campground I
think it's like a former like YMCA camp
or whatever and for a couple days like
an extended weekend they open it up to
like their hardcore fans who come from
like all over the world who get to like
live in these cabins for a couple days
when the band is like there and they
perform at night and they're kind of
available and they hang out that's off
and they have cool people come in and
speak and it's all very like positive
and there's no like there's no booze
it's like oh wow totally clean and it's
just like they're hardcore people that
like love them and like basically these
like private concerts for them at night
and they film it they made that you know
they make little movies out of it and
stuff like that but I was like that's
that's the future you know that's really
cool like a personal it's hang with them
yeah that's awesome and just be like we
don't need all that other all the
machinations of the industry like yeah
we have our people that love us and
let's like take care of them yeah they
were really cool there's um there's a
story that I think they'll never forget
two stories is that one during throwing
that tour with them my guitar player
stole one of the tour buses while the
bus drives was sleeping the hotel and
Austin thirty Seconds to Mars and all
the beds crammed into the bus and we
drove to Bam Margera's house for like a
party that night and rusty or a guitar
player was driving the bus and we came
back to the parking lot and all the bus
drivers were standing there in the
parking lot so bummed and another thing
is that we about to play in New York
City and this is when thirty Seconds to
Mars was like blowing up and growing and
they asked us a favor they said you mind
if we play after you in New York and
that's like a big favor to ask special
wit that's our hometown and we were like
sure
so we let them it was a no big deal for
us we knew we're gonna have a good show
they have a good show
but I think they never forgot that that
we let them play afterwards because her
label is going to be there
really that was the Eleazar really good
time and every time I see and they're
always so awesome to me and stuff and it
was cool and I haven't seen him after
they like blew up after that I was right
pretty amazing now what's the what is
the day today like reality of like you
know being like a hardcore punk you know
versus like you know what someone
imagines it might be you know I don't
know MIT it's the same thing you say
about rock and rollers do you think that
these rock and roll's are like partying
all day and so but the hardcore do is a
totally opposite yeah like you've been
married for a long time all you do is
talk about like how much you love your
wife yeah you know yeah so I just from
made from magic my daily life was a hike
every day I eat gravy I work out I do my
I do my online sales working my podcast
I book all the tourists coming up I
design all the merch for all the
tourists like me and out of my bass
player by managing the band for over ten
years we do everything DIY and yeah I go
to bed like at 10 o'clock my whole life
stays up later than I do like people
think it's it's not what people think it
is
especially if in rock and roll but I
honestly feel like John Joseph's like
all of us hardcore do is everybody's
eaten like salads and greens stuff and
we're stretching we play John's like
chanting Hari Krishna yeah it's totally
not what people think it is man it's
it's it's especially just musicians in
general people think it's this glamorous
wonderful you're going to Europe all
summer to the festivals but the
traveling is brutal those 23 hours in
queue get to play like trying to find
food and a town getting sleep you're
jet-lagged but you have that 45 minutes
to an hour every night just to give it
everything you got that's that's the
best part of tour but this other 23
hours when all your family can be really
dark and depressing
luckily for FaceTime and this phone
which is a powerful thing it changed
everything for touring having face time
the car your family that's amazing but
Tony's not all glamour especially when
you're older it's even if you're vegan
you're in great shape it doesn't matter
man it's just a strenuous of touring and
you know having that energy so yeah and
when I'm home I'm just chilling I'm so
lucky when I'm home I did everything out
of my house
I don't have to leave my house when I go
to my only cross does he like to my
little spots I do my Runyon King I stay
and my little p.m. a bubble and just do
my little round so I'm like take my
birds
taking the birds around you have birds
those little bird things little bird
scooters oh the bird scooters yeah
but I do live in this I do find myself
guilty of living this like PMA bubble if
everything's wonderful and we're all
love each other and I don't really look
at the news that much I check out Vice
from time to time and but I in my world
in my community as long as I know my
friends and my family are good and I'm
trying to like you know I go to the
vigils the pig vigils and do that I try
to do my part but I do live in this in
the world that I'm that one day
everybody's gonna be all United and
wonderful like a perfect Benetton ad
we're all gonna be together it's gonna
be like this like I do it's not I do
live in a little fantasy world or that
I'm guilty of that like well you can't
be PMA and not be optimistic totally but
you can't be Pollyanna either yeah I
know my wife's like I'm a realist in
your listen so yeah I just yeah man my
daily life was just do you go to shows
yeah I went to I went to a show last
week and I actually sang a song with
gula biscuits one of my favorite bands a
good Minor Threat song with him had two
of their sets at the Roxy it was awesome
so that was fun
went star chrome I see my boys when they
come to town they go to those shows and
but I also go to like bigger shows my
son like I took him to see Travis Scott
and that was crazy was a mosh pit
people were diving it was like I looked
at my son I go why is your he goes I
can't leave as a mosh pit here he goes
why there's one of your show and I had
no answers for him like okay that's the
generation like there was it would go to
like Katy I love Katy Perry mm-hmm she
likes on my finger I've KP I'm crazy
oh wow um so um I go like these other
bigger shows in my son and just check
those vibes now I like going to concerts
yeah I'm out and about I do my thing and
what it would it max Inc your son think
about going on tour with you I mean his
first tour he was super young it was
Japan twice he was like three and then
six I have to take him back to Japan he
can appreciate it now but yeah if he's
been to South America he's been to
Ireland he's been everywhere he loves it
now I'm making him work before he's a
little kid now it's like yo you need to
get the towels the water I'm making him
work for his pre-dam
you know like he's got a hustle now he
knows it and he plays one song per night
where's my money I played one song huh
so he loves seeing the world and like
obviously I don't think that our parents
were happy that we're taking our son on
tour but it's like this is what happened
to me when I moved to New York I got to
see the world at a very young age it
opened my mind to see different cultures
and made me who I am today and to be
able to bring max on tour at this young
age and see the world and play live it's
it's it's amazing that can be able even
do that with even the band and I'm not
even in big bands the fact I can take
him to have the experience he loves he
looks forward to it he's 16 now we're
going this time I'm not sure when he's
17 I'm gonna be cool enough to go on
tour but this one's a 21 day one it's a
really big one he's so psyched and I
always plan his tours a week after he
gets out of school so he has like a week
with his friends and then they take him
away for the summer but yeah I'm lucky
to do that he loves him and it's
definitely made him a more rounded human
well to see the world in that way yeah
what do you need cool experience
yeah the different cultures different
foods and just the people and like does
he have a sense of what he wants to do
man he's an amazing drummer he only
wants to play music he's exactly like me
when I was in that when I was his age he
can't he does not like school he's
struggling with his grades and the
things he doesn't care about he does
great in science and history he just
he's in a magnet program so the band
recorded they have an adidas sound lab
which is amazing they record their first
single they have a manager who's an 11th
grade at their school but on the school
label the band played two shows it was
packed
I don't even know what's happening um
he's an incredible drummer that's what
he wants to do so I gotta support it man
he just I love it their managers in 11th
grade I know he calls for the clown ask
me questions it's like huh it's crazy so
he's exactly like me
I was I was into music and escape when
he's exactly like me it's so scary but
I'm like listen how you have two more
years left you just have to get out of
school you just have to graduate I'm
really asking for C's Mayer B's and C's
this I just get out I've been there just
get out get through the school and then
we'll figure you want to do it I mean
it's hard because I can it and he knows
because I obviously he knows everything
about me I remember you got these grades
are you I'm like but that's me here
different I want you be a better better
who I don't know a better example of
what I was like it's what it's hard when
like I know exactly what he's going
through man he's playing air drums on
the table he's just like yeah drummers
there just think about that way man
you know ya identify it right away and
you're like up
that's drunk now so it's it's no what's
your interesting you played a school
concert last week and it was all like
this girl singing amazing singers at
school and then I'm standing in the
crowd and then here kids go his band's
called Randall like bends up next and
then all the kids are running into this
room and they're starting like mosh pits
at a school musical thing like they're
in next to be like slam dancing for my
son's band and then three of his
teachers can't he's not doing so good in
the classes and they said to me they go
I get your son now I totally get it they
saw how amazing of a drummer he was and
they're realizing why such a spaz and
they know that he's like maybe on this
path to be a musician uh-huh and I got
to meet them and then one of it one of
the teams like yeah I like Black Flag
and house crew he's trying to bond with
me of our punk it was really cute and
then oh but I see that he's on this
musical path and like he's an incredible
drummer and and they get it now
yeah cuz they only seen max in the
classroom you know like it's uncle
Travis giving him some tips
Travis has for sure for sure Travis game
is first cowbell actually too as a
cowbell and Mackay from the cro-mags is
another one really tell him a lot of
really great staying in the pocket and
the rhythms and he's got all these
people to round up the new musicians
this I'm not surprised at what's
happening you know that's pretty cool
yeah it's pretty it's pretty a pretty
lucky man and we'll see what happens
with everybody needs a drummer you know
it's not going out of style but usually
the drummer is the guy who's trouble
it's it's true yeah it's true but he's
not he's like totally like he's a model
playing the drums so it's it's uh is
it's it's cool man but yeah the grades
things little stressful and just gonna
make it through a man because I've been
there yeah but that modeling of you know
being the example for your kid and and
kind of walking the talk I think is like
the key thing like there's you know look
like you said like none of us are
perfect but we can't tell our kids to do
one thing and then behave differently
like those things have to be in
alignment and you've got to create
enough trust so that they feel safe and
they they have the willingness to come
to you and be honest you know because I
feel like you know when kids start to
get into adolescence like the walls
start to come up
and then you got to work like extra hard
to make sure that channel stays open
because it will close so easily if
you're not like he's carrying top of it
yeah he came up he came home a couple
weeks ago and said can I get a hand
poked tattoo I was like first of all
you're 16 me and it's kids are giving
tattoos in the back of the classroom now
it's a good trendy thing to get hand
poked at I heard about this even on
girls and I'm like listen you can have
any tattoo artists in the whole world
look at me just ask me anything you have
to wait to you're 18 but he's like my
friend's game at 16 like oh I'm not your
friends and my friends you know but I
can't say you can't get tattoo obviously
but I'll take you to a shop and you're
18 like I did and you get a professional
tattoo and like but because all the kids
are doing the hand poked is like forget
one little one I'm like no but least
he's asking me you know what's even cute
he'll be like he's me so embarrassed I'm
even talking about this like he'll text
me go all my friends have skipped in
seventh period can I skip seventh period
he'll ask people missing to skip a class
man oh man it's got emotionally about
that none of these kids are asking their
parents that they could skip a class it
was skipping the class and that that
open channel of communication is so much
more important compared to whether he's
gonna skip that class or not 100% of
fact he's asking me liking cares if I be
bombed him like sure like what class is
that what your grade in their class like
it's crazy because I know that no other
kids having that common conversation no
and so I never want that communication
and I want this is such a strong bond me
my son have I know when I can be
together forever and that reality for me
it's really it's a hard pill to swallow
because I know he's 16 though a couple
years give me 18 I know my mom kicked me
out when I was 17
I'm never kicking my so he can stay
there to his liking but separation is
natural what it is and you needs that
yeah I know at some point I know I saw
something similar there that same like
we don't own our children like they're
with us now but we don't own them they
get to leave and just it's crazy because
I want that that bond forever and I'm
sure it's gonna be a different bond you
know a distant bond whatever but was so
lucky to be parents man you know why uh
why start a podcast
cuz everybody been telling me start a
podcast for years and I'm like you can
just like talk and all my friends have
them and I think I started too late but
I'm so Farah Punic man like the way I'm
doing it chronological order of my life
and interview and every single person
that's met me up until now
like I'm sitting on like 50 episodes
done Wow like it's been so awesome
having conversations and like especially
my mom and digging up stuff about my dad
and my brothers like we none of us had
therapy we all need therapy 100% that's
a different story but it was very
therapeutic to start that way and then
get into all my friends and start
talking to them and spin it's been
interesting man to have these
conversations and I don't know why I
started doing it and it's it's really
fun yeah why did you start when it's
cool I started it well first of all I
started 2012 was like no one was doing
it you know like it was not I say this
all the time but like definitely was not
cool to have a podcast back yeah it
wasn't like people were clamoring to
start one yeah you know when you told
people you had one they just looked at
you strangely so it's odd and I never
would have predicted that it would
become like this medium that people
would want to be involved with but I
will say that I got into it because I
was an early adopter as a consumer of
the meat like I've gotten trained for
these races I'd be on my bike like all
day I can't listen to music you know at
so many audiobooks at the time so I
started listening to podcasts and I was
like holy [ __ ] this is like there's like
incredible information here for free
that's like right why isn't everybody
listening to this so I really enjoyed it
and it really enriched my life at that
time and I've been evangelizing it ever
since and been frustrated that more
people couldn't understand like what you
know I was experiencing and a part of
that was because the technology wasn't
seamless enough for people to make it
you know easy for them because you would
have to download them on your laptop and
then bounce it to your iPod this is like
pre iPhone yeah so it's like you had to
really kind of like wanna do it but I
started it just because I'd written a
book and yeah yeah book did its thing
and then when that was done it was like
alright well what's next and I was like
well I could start a putt nobody was
really doing anything all that
compelling in the health and fitness
sector and it was an opportunity to kind
of continue the conversation that the
book started and yeah I was like I know
some interesting people and but kind of
like you go into New York like I was
like I did an episode it wasn't like I'm
gonna Bank all these episodes and here's
my strategy and this is how it's gonna
be a business I was like I just turned a
mic on and my wife and I had a
conversation I was like that's cool
do it tomorrow when I did it I didn't
know if I there would be a second
episode yeah I didn't really know what I
was doing and I did it for years before
it became a thing that actually you know
I could make money off of to like you
know support my family
Wow so started for I feel like I started
for the right reasons
yeah and it's kind of remained true to
what it always was from the beginning
which is an opportunity for me to just
connect with people that inspire me in
different ways and learn from them yeah
and what's been cool about it is that so
many of these people then become my
friends you know and my advisers and
people that are like in my life which is
awesome like the greatest gift of the
whole thing yeah because he gives me an
excuse they like call people up like you
and go hey you gotta drive to my house
and I'm gonna hold you hostage for the
afternoon I love it I'm yeah it's really
it's really been fun to having
conversations and talking to people
getting to know people yeah I didn't
expect it to go the way it's going to
it's doing pretty well for how long it's
been out and well the chronology thing
is cool like let's start beginning and
just like work through your life and all
these yeah impacted you yeah it's been
really fun but it's kind of hard
tracking people down I'm like doing the
ones over the phone but I have to do
because people spread out but yeah it's
been interesting hear people's stories
and how we met and then stuff we've
evolved in together and they won't budge
on I can't what come yeah they did my
yeah it's been really really fun I have
such a diverse group of people with to
like skaters and actors and musicians to
just like you and just to talk to people
it's been really fun but uh the reason
why I did a bunch in advance because I'm
gonna be touring all summer I don't know
how this is gonna go if I was you were
gonna keep doing the podcast but now
they haven't read I can just go on tour
not worry about that's what's right yeah
yeah yeah that's calm but it's fun to
get to know people and um yeah man just
stuff yeah have you have you done with
Brolin I'm gonna do you want you gotta
do oh gee rajion friend how did you
become friends with that guy I love
following him unbelievable he's amazing
amazing I'm AI met him outside of
crossroads actually he wasn't even going
to crossroads I was with my friend my
friend Luke wessman and he had his
lowrider out there and he was taking
photos in front of the lowrider and we
just met that day and then I don't know
if I followed him he follow me and start
falling then I hung out a couple times
since and he's he's awesome we text all
the time he hit me up today he's doing
great things he comes from the
the dog town old-school communities in
the band cart RKL we play drums he was a
punk rocker comes from the same scene
it's pretty awesome I mean he's like an
artist and a poet trapped in a star's
body his writing is incredible so
incredible so humble so nice
I'm so happy from all that stuff he's
doing the superhero stuff like killing
it you had a super cool dude it's very
grounded you know like I love that but
yeah I mean it comes from the art world
it's it's pretty crazy I don't even knew
that I didn't know that about him sir
I'm in about the RKO thing which kids on
LSD know punk band
yeah he's written about it a little bit
yeah I've seen it's pretty cool
he's these good people man he's good
it's gonna go some way like on that
level of talent and in Hollywood it's
like one of us it's really cool he just
he just seems he's got his wits about
him in the right way ya know and you can
when you see like when you read his
stuff and you kind of follow him you
can't help but like root for him yeah I
know what I mean yeah it was writing so
amazing and you came on here what about
a book for you man you got a book in you
yeah I was thinking I was thinking that
this podcast is almost like an audiobook
of the book I haven't written yet yeah
you know I just feel like I think that
might happen when I get older I'm gonna
do that I could see myself doing so I
don't know man be cool but this this
podcast definitely helped those stories
and helped me focus on that I started
writing one like maybe like a year ago
just writing different chapters of stuff
but I'll do one yeah cool we cool well I
want to land this plane but I can't let
you go without kind of leaving some
parting words for you know somebody
who's listening who's out there who
feels stuck maybe they're in that
cubicle job or they're living a life
that you know they feel like they didn't
even consciously choose for themselves
and just having trouble you know
accessing that font of positivity that
seems to come so natural to you or
they're feeling you know creatively
stymied or you know powerless in their
life and yeah somebody who you know
spends a lot of time like connecting
with young people and encouraging them
and trying to be you know this sort of
receivership for positive energy and
possibility like how do you speak to
that person I mean I would say first and
foremost
look up Napoleon Hill read Think and
Grow Rich successful positive mental
attitude
and I feel personally that I was in
crappy jobs too before everything
changed for me I was working in mail
rooms I was working with asbestos
building the sound Factory in Manhattan
I was doing a bunch of stuff that I was
so miserable doing that I just one of
the last ones I did was like I can't do
this anymore there's something I really
want to do I just went for it I feel
like nobody's really trapped in a
miserable job
there's always like you always have
opportunities to do something else
nobody's forcing you do that I know
people have bills and families in there
and they're they're going through a lot
of stuff but everybody goes through
stuff and I feel like you just gotta
it's so corny and cliche to say like
believe in yourself and push through it
but like I'm living proof that you don't
have to do something like I was doing
stuff just to get by and I wasn't happy
doing it before when I was I wrote
before was a roadie and stuff and um I
just feel like you just kind of believe
in yourself and push through and realize
that you don't have to it's about being
happy we're only here temporarily and
this is like this could end tomorrow and
in being happy and and loving your life
and being healthy it makes everything so
much better your perspective on life so
much better it's easier said than done
granted but I feel like if you're
working at a job and you're miserable
you gotta leave gotta quit that job you
have to leave that job you have to take
a chance one life one chance that's my
mom you have to take a chance and try to
do something to love like my band wasn't
supposed to make it my band was a total
joke I wasn't a singer we had so much
backlash my first band started when we
kept doing it because we believed in the
message we were doing we believed in
everything we're doing and because of
that it worked and if you just believe
in yourself and and say you had some job
and you believe you won't do something
else just just do it do it now don't
wait don't procrastinate because life
could be over tomorrow and I do live in
the moment a lot and I don't anything
about the future a lot which is a bad
thing but it's worked out okay it's
worked out okay for me but like there's
no reason to be miserable there's no
reason to be miserable in a job and hate
what you're doing like somehow you got
yourself in that position there's a way
to get yourself out of that position
nobody forced you into that position
you guys understand I'm saying so you
have all the power to do what you want
to do you might not get there right away
we have to work for it and maybe work at
a different job to get into the space
you want to be in but just don't give up
believe in yourself all sounds corny
cliche but I
49 year old man's been doing everything
I love almost my whole entire life
because I never gave up and I believed
in myself when other people are
believing in me and that's the key to a
happy life is doing what you love I
think and so get yourself out of that
job and try something else and push
yourself and don't give up but don't
quit
that's all I can tell you do thank you
very much boom just put a punctuation
mark on podcast perfect way to end it
Thank You Man thank you thank you yeah
that was epic thank you for having me
I'm honored to meet you real life super
cool like to hang out you after this
yeah yeah definitely man more more will
be revealed and to be continued come
back and talk to me anytime and be
awesome I look forward to getting to
know you even better thank you it shall
be more sure and inspiration appreciate
you thank you [ __ ] my podcast yeah of
course one life one chance podcast there
you go it's everywhere
Toby Moore's on all the social media
channels and it's one life one chance
calm for the net profit correct
and what's your my podcast you and yeah
anytime man well have to be the last
episode because I'm the most recent
person that you've met so it's gonna be
season 20 or something next year yeah
I'll come to Hollywood any time also
Toby's got amazing super cool merch so
if you want to find that it's like issue
emerge calm yes yeah anything else
anything else coming up also 25th
anniversary age 12 be on tour all summer
in Europe we playing all around the
state so we have a secret surprise show
may 18th in Los Angeles on the one
that's coming out I'm happy there yeah
we just look up on our website look on
our Facebook which is h2o family and
yeah we're around you can find us
everywhere thanks to these phones this
social media world
alright peace implants my friends piece
of play
[Music]